what's the origin story here how did
this all come about maybe David and Joel
could take that one not to me I had done
the plays 20 years ago that's kind of
where it started I think I performed
when I was 25 I guess Henry four parts
one and two and the following year we
did Henry the fifth Esther's in
Australia and we taught it around so you
know I've done over a hundred
performances of both both productions
and it's just been on my mind for such a
long time and you know you know 15 years
later the opportunity arose for me to
get behind creating projects and
producing things and coming up with
ideas for things and and I'd been asked
about doing various movies that were
like you know period films that that I
didn't really that didn't really pull on
my interest levels of my heartstrings
and but felt reflective of and inspired
by Shakespearean epic kind of tales and
and it made me think about the plays
again and I thought well it had been 25
years since browning had done Henry the
fifth would somebody be interested in
making a film about Henry and that's
where it started and that's when I
started having conversations with David
and the studio that I spoke to
to their credit gave us the opportunity
to write a version of that and and and
it was soon after that that we decided
that rather than just work with the text
that in order to make a film that wasn't
so much a show of kind of empirical
might and war as a sense of national
identity and pride that we might need to
go our own different way with all
reference in respect to Shakespeare that
would we be able to create our own
version using Henry v as a center piece
and and look at real history borrow some
things from the plays but also take her
own license what was your part of this
journey
I changed other than directing that's up
well Joel came Joel and I live you know
we've were very very very good friends
we'd live very close to each other in
Sydney we see each other a lot and one
day I think we were literally sitting on
Bondi Beach and Joel said hey I've had
an idea and a you know Henry the fifth
and I I it sounded like a terrible idea
to me it was exciting to me because we
knew actually what we wanted to do
something very different you know it's
not just about you know the kind of
movie we were gonna we wanted to make it
wasn't going to lend itself to a direct
adaptation you know that that verse as
glorious as it is written for
Elizabethan presentation you know and
but also just on a somatic level you
know I wanted to tell a kind of
different story to the one that
Shakespeare was telling which is the
idea of a young you know that they're
both stories about a young king but they
were one was about a young you know
idealistic but kind of naive man rather
than him just grappling with his
conscience he's actually being sucked
into a kind of paranoid isolated bubble
of power letting himself be manipulated
by you know the cabal of sort of weird
neo-cons floating around him and and so
I actually took you know knowing that we
were never really going to be able to
leave Shakespeare behind it it liberated
me to know that for our intents and
purposes that's what we would be doing
we're actually just gonna do our own
thing and so we didn't we never really
even talked about Shakespeare after
those very early conversations and so
Timothy this is this this particular
incarnation of Henry v this is we're
saying quite a very different departure
from previous incarnations and you
really you know you vocal ease crazy
conflicts and contradictions that are
inherent in this character what what
attracted you
this material in first place hmm David
no well a lot of things I think David
directed animal kingdom which some of my
favorite movies before I ever got a
chance to do Q&A is like this or got a
chance to work on anything big but then
I loved that almost all of David's
movies without speaking for him deal
with uh what we call now a toxic
masculinity and maybe throughout history
were just the the the either evil or
induced evil whims of men and and I read
it and I really couldn't see myself in
it and that was very exciting and I
thought the script was excellent but
then in talking to David and realizing
there was no contest with Kenneth
Branagh or Laurence Olivier because
simply because it'd be hopeless and
because I'm a young American and and
they you know gave near flawless
performances and now we know when Dave
explained to me the language wasn't the
same here and this was the attempt at
getting a searing portrait of a young
man in circumstance that's too great for
him with a skill set that in a level of
experience and a level of a political
experience and familial experience that
is that is no good for the circumstance
at hand and then lastly was the
opportunity you know it's something I'm
really grateful for just in my career
thus far that I feel like I get to jump
into well-oiled machines and you know
DeeDee Gardner and Plan B not only do
they make some of my favorite movies but
they had put me in a movie last year
called beautiful boy and and thank you
and I guess I get to say Brad Pitt
produced both of these but that's a very
weird thing to say out loud and and and
and really I got to jump into this
Australian you know creative circus that
travels well but David and Joel but our
detour cinematographer who just [ __ ]
killed it in this movie at a markup ah
and
ben mendelsohn as well and then lastly
it'll be quiet and the youngest one here
people don't hear me but that uh that
Nicholas Patel who's sitting here makes
the most extraordinary music in movies
today if I could say that to get to do
this at a young age jump in with people
that are the best at their at their
craft I'm just going it's it's Fellig a
no-brainer Nicholas here you've got this
sort of simultaneous thing going on
where you're evoking a sense of the past
but you're doing something that's very
very contemporary very present and also
very mysterious you talk about that
strategy and also which our
collaboration with David was like
absolutely thank you very much and thank
you Timothy respect you know I'm always
fascinated with those early those first
instincts that you have when you see a
film for the first time and I watched
the film very early this year with no
music and I think the first thought I
had you know I'm not sure where this
came from but I said to myself you know
what if this were the 25th century and
not the 15th century what would that
sound like and I think there was this
feeling of these are themes that exist
for every generation to ask you know
these are questions of intellectual
fraud what's true what's false to whom
do we entrust our power a power of the
state questions that are relevant for
every era and I was just wondering like
what would a sound be that didn't
necessarily feel like it was rooted in
the early 1400s but actually could feel
like it was sometime in the future even
and that was some of the first
conversations that David and I had and
David was totally into these kind of
questions so I started experimenting
with what I thought might be very sort
of strange sounds like like looking at
the early 1400s like they were this
foreign planet so I took these bass
clarinets and played them out of their
range and ran them through this sort of
tape filter which created this almost
like strange human sound and Dave and I
spent a whole week in March in my studio
in New York where we were just really
playing with sounds taking metal and
bending it and seeing what that did but
then I did a whole deep dive on
late medieval and early Renaissance
music exploring the even the music in
England at that time John Donne stable
and like and I think it was important to
do that but at the same time David felt
very strongly that we didn't want it to
feel he read in that way because I think
then it made it feel like the story was
really about the early 1400s when it
really isn't just about the 1400s so I
think what what came together was a
sound that actually incorporated a lot
of strings which felt to us very
timeless you know this sound that could
be in any era and I think the harmonies
and the sort of way that I orchestrated
is something that felt like it it was in
inspired by some of the openness of that
early renaissance late medieval period
but it also had elements of other eras
too so I'm almost not exactly sure how
to pin down the exact harmonic that I
was using but there was also a sound of
a boy's choir which felt symbolically
resonant with the story of this young
man becoming King and yeah and I think
that that all came together in a way
that felt right to us and and
represented hopefully many eras you talk
about the the physical production itself
yeah I mean that was this movie we knew
was never gonna be easy you know and it
was never gonna be cheap
it was and for that reason it was always
going to be difficult to make because
it's not a you know it's not gladiator
it's not it's not the triumph of good
over evil you know in a way it's a story
about a young man well-intentioned young
man kind of you know unwittingly being
turned into a tyrant by the Machine
around him you know but it was never you
know when we first started developing
this at a different studio you know it
was like we had it bad early budget on
it but like a hundred and ten million
you know okay how we gonna do that
because there was Dee Dee's problem we
made it for less than half of that yeah
so when we took time when we went in
epics they were still going to resource
it properly but it's like you know basic
they saying be smart about it you know
how are you doing it how are you going
to achieve this stuff and in a way that
I think it actually ends up suiting the
way I like to work which is it forces
you to think you know triple think
everything you're doing you know and go
through the script again triple think
all the decisions you're making because
I always find that that beautiful things
come out of that I'm reticent to call it
compromise because it isn't it's just
being rigorous in your interrogation of
the material and how you are planning to
execute it but then every now and then
something happens like you know they you
know we've got those that The Trevor
shows they're called you know and I
remember being in an early
pre-production meeting with the art
department they said so how many of
these do you want and I just said three
you know expecting someone to tell me at
some point later down the track that
you're gonna get half of one and we'll
see you the rest there was never another
conversation about I just turned up in
Hungary a few months later and there are
three of these [ __ ] things you know
there and they're amazing and we we shot
the [ __ ] out of them can you talk to me
about the physical challenges of putting
all this together you've invoked such an
interesting post medieval world you've
worked in multiple countries but what
were the challenges there I think for
this one it was a Zonk or budgetarily we
realized that we couldn't shoot it all
in the UK after we got that number and
so we had to find a rebate able place to
do the line share of the production and
then we had to send David there in
February when it was covered and so and
say definitely find your valley which he
did bless him
yeah I would I would say Agincourt for
all the obvious reasons the mud the heat
the horses the battle the armor but also
for the safety anxiety just a constant
prayer every day all day long let's all
get out of here okay
honestly because it was there was just
proximity was intense for a long period
of time and wanting these guys to stay
safe and happy and feel like they're
getting everything that they want and
also wanting to get out of there okay
and I want to thank you all for your
comments I think we're out of time